I want to take up in Volume 3, from February the 20th, 1900, and hear the subject is light.
My good Jesus continues to come, Louisa says, "After I received Communion, he renewed in
me the pains of the crucifixion, and I was left so numb that I felt the need for a relief,
but I didn't dare ask for it."
After what she'd been told, a few messages earlier, "After a little while Jesus came
back as an infant, as a baby, and he blessed me, milk flowed from his lips, and I drank
in large gulps, that most sweet milk that comes from his lips."
Now we need to remember that when Jesus comes as an infant, Louisa's going to be talking
about either receiving milk from him or giving it, and you just need to remember that in
the earliest stage of life that milk represents life itself.
So now while I was doing this, Jesus told me, "I am the flower of the celestial Eden,
and in the fragrance I spread is such that my perfume perfumes the whole of heaven and
keeps heaven captivated."
So the flower, I just want to give you one reference for that you could find from the
Song of Songs, chapter 2 and verse 1.
In the Song of Songs, he is the Rose of Charon and the Lily of the Valley.
And since I am the lamp, that is the light of the world, that's John 812 and John 9.5,
since I am the light that sends light to everyone, so much so as to keep them immersed in it,
all of my saints draw their little lights from me.
So there's no light in heaven which has not been drawn from this lamp.
This is described quite well in Revelation 21, verses 23 to 24, where in the New Jerusalem
where everybody's living in the Divine will, there's no need for sunlight or daylight because
Christ is our light.
And Louisa says, "I, yes, there's not even the smell of virtue without Jesus.
And even if one went up to the highest heaven, there's no light without him, so he's the
Alpha and the Omega at the beginning and the end, that's Revelation 1, 17 to 18."
Now we go on to February the 21st, 1900, and the subject is pure purity.
And I want to give you a whole lot of references, and they're not all, indeed.
Matthew 5, 8, only the pure and heart see God, Philippians 1, 10, and also chapter 4, verse
8.
The first letter of St. Paul to Timothy, chapter 1, verse 5 and chapter 5, verse 22, and the
letter to Titus, chapter 1, verse 15, and Hebrews 10, 22, that's just to get you going
on this subject.
This morning, my beloved Jesus began to make his usual delays.
May he always be blessed, for he always starts from the beginning.
Indeed, it takes patience, the patience of a saint to bear with him.
I just find this absolutely unbelievable, and one would have to deal with Jesus to see
how much patience it takes.
One who was not experienced cannot believe it, and it's almost impossible not to have
a few hops with him.
I think her language is absolutely fantastic, because it's revealing such a close relationship
with Jesus, that it's telling all the rest of us that this relationship is real.
This is not just mystical as in up in the air, and no contact with reality.
This is very real, and they are both relating in a very real way to each other.
And Louisa thinks she thought she had solved the privation problem, and then she finds
that Jesus disappears again, and that's what she means by our back at the beginning, we're
at the start again, and it's very difficult to have patience with him.
That's because we're halfway through Volume 3, and she has not yet learned, he's told
her in plain language, that she's to take it with patience, she's to surrender to the
divine will, she's to offer it for love of him, and so on, and so on.
That's okay if you're not going through the pain that she's going through and confined
to a bed with absolutely no distraction.
So the heading of the next paragraph is suffering for love of Jesus, it's the only acceptable
motivation.
Why?
Because God is love, then Louisa said, "After being patient in waiting and waiting for
him, finally he came, and he told me, 'My daughter, the gift of purity, in other words
he doesn't deal with the privation, he's probably tired of it.
My daughter, the gift of purity is not a natural gift.
It's an attained grace, and it's obtained by rendering oneself worthy of sympathy, which
I think is very interesting, I wouldn't have thought of this in two million years.
The soul becomes worthy of sympathy through mortification and suffering, or how worthy
of sympathy becomes the mortified and suffering soul, how striking she is, and I feel such
sympathy as to go mad for her, and whatever she wants, I give her.
When you are deprived of me, I want to add the words, 'Would you please suffer my privation
for love of me?'
Which is the most painful suffering for you, and I will feel more sympathy than before
and grant you new gifts.
So if only you would accept it, if only you would surrender to the fact that this is going
to happen, and if only you would offer it for love of Jesus, then things can move on.
Now she'll take one step forward and three steps backwards, just like we do on things
we find difficult.
So February the 23rd, 1900, the subject is discernment.
This morning after I had almost lost the hope that blessed Jesus would come, all of a sudden
he came and renewed in me the pains of the crucifixion.
And he told me, 'The time has come, the end is approaching, but the hour is uncertain.'
So I want to give you Amos 3-7 that the Lord never does anything without telling the prophets
first.
I also want to give you Revelation 11-1 when we're told the time has come.
Okay.
Now this is the beginning of the 20th century, and Jesus is saying it's the end times.
Now lots of commentators around the world have caught on to the fact that we are in end time
eschatology, and it's end time events that are happening around us, and the amount of
chastisements that have happened on the earth is just off the richter scale, but we still
don't get the message that if we repented things would change.
So having been told that the time has come, the end is approaching, and that the hour
is uncertain, Louisa said, 'Without paying attention to the meaning of the words that
he spoke, I still had a doubt about whether I should apply them to the complete crucifixion
that she's just experienced, or to the chastisements.'
So she said to Jesus, 'Lord, how I fear that my state may not be the will of God, and she's
doing at this for three volumes, and get used to it, and get patient about it, it's going
to go on.'
She does continuous discernment about this.
She's right.
The road she was on was different to everybody else, and while there were priests there, they
could listen and offer their responses, but they couldn't tell her where she was going.
Jesus said, 'The surest sign to know whether the state you are in is in the divine will
is that you find the strength to sustain it.'
So you have the strength to do something, you may be suffering, it may cost you an awful
lot, but if you have the strength and the stamina to do it, and the certainty and the
depths of your being that that's what you're called to, then it is the divine will.
And Jesus said, 'When a person becomes intimate with the family, one no longer uses those
formalities, those regards which they used before, even when they were a stranger.'
That's the way I do it.
But nevertheless, this is not a sign that it's not the will of the family to have the
person with them, or that they no longer love them as before.
It's just the circumstances have changed.
'Therefore,' he said, 'be at peace, let me do,' and he's going to plead with her so
often to let him have his way.
Do not want to rack your brains or trouble the peace of your heart.
Now, the thing that was going to bring that, one of the things that was going to bring
the 20th century down was rationalism.
We want to rationalize everything, we want to bring all reality down within the confines
of our tiny little brains.
And if they don't fit within the confines of our little brains, we don't accept it.
Therefore, truth and mystery and God and creation and life and everything is beyond us, because
it's all part of this extraordinary mystery.
So it begs your not to rationalize, and not to trouble the peace of our heart.
If I want to give you SAM 131 there, my soul is like a weaned child on its mother's lap.
At the appropriate time, you will understand how I'm working.
It's not really until you get to the higher volumes that Louisa becomes not only fully
aware of what he's doing, but realizes the plan that he's doing, and she becomes a completely
different person at that stage.
But what he does between now and then is that he explains everything little by little to
her, and he's explaining it little by little to us, so I'm not going to jump ahead and
tell you something ahead of Valian 3, I wouldn't be right, because we can only take things piece
by piece according to the grace that's been given to us.
So February the 24th, 1900, the subject is obedience, and the Lord has demanded that
Louisa be the obedient one like himself, but this time she's having a problem.
This morning I was all fear.
Now we have to know that fear is the greatest weapon of the enemy, and if fear gets into
us, he can produce all kinds of problems.
I believe that everything was fantasy, she said.
That is, the devil wanting to deceive me.
So whatever I would see, I would despise, and I would be displeased.
I saw the Confess replacing the intention that Jesus would renew in me the pains of the crucifixion,
and I tried to resist.
At first, blessed Jesus tolerated me, but since the Confessor kept repeating, they request.
Jesus told me, "My daughter, at this time we are really going to fail in obedience.
Don't you know that obedience must seal your soul, and that obedience must render the soul
like soft wact in such a way that the Confessor may give to it the shape he wants."
Now, even though she's at this very high level of union with God, and she has been gifted
and graced to such an extraordinary degree, that doesn't mean that your will isn't completely
free and that your emotions aren't free to express themselves, okay?
And so the Lord is saying to her, "I need a deeper surrender.
A surrender like melted wact has that you can put it into any shape at all."
So you'll find as we go on in the volumes that Louisa is tested at the absolute extreme
of obedience.
It's one thing to call it heroism, but she's actually brought to the extreme where a human
being can't go.
So heedless of my resistance, Louisa says, "Jesus shared with me the pains of the crucifixion."
And what you have there is that both God and Satan recognize the authority that a priest
has in exorcisms, Satan will obey a command of a priest, and he won't obey a layman in
an exorcism.
I don't mean a deliverance.
A deliverance is a lesser thing.
An exorcism is on the level of miracle.
And the devil will respond to a priest who has proper authority from God.
Do you remember in the Acts of the Apostles, the sons of Scaver were acting as exorcists
and they started trying to get the devil out of people by saying, "I command you by the
Jesus whom Paul serves."
And the devil attacked them and said, "What right do you have to command me?
Paul is appointed by Jesus.
You're not.
You don't even believe in him.
You just think you can use this yourselves."
The devil just attacked them.
So here you have Jesus giving the crucifixion to Louisa because of the authority that's
in the priest, he recognizes it and responds to it.
So Louisa said, "I wasn't able to resist after this, and I didn't want to for fear
that it might not be Jesus, I'll say exactly what she says, and I no longer able to resist
all this, which I did not want for fear that it might not be Jesus.
I was forced to succumb under the weight of the pain.
May he be always blessed, and may everything be for his glory in everything and always.
So I want to give you Ephesians chapter 3 verses 20 and 21.
And now we come to a very important moment in volume 3.
It's February the 26th, 1900.
And this is the very first deep teaching on divine will in these volumes.
After going through several days of privation, at most Jesus would come sometimes like a
shadow and would run away.
I felt such pain that I consumed myself with tears.
Now in higher volumes, the tears will be completely gone, she won't even remember them.
Having compassion for my sorrow, blessed Jesus came, and he looked and looked at me
again, and he said to me, "My daughter, do not fear, for I do not leave you."
That's the book of Joshua chapter 1 verse 5.
And 1 Corinthians 3, 16, "No you not that you are the temple of the living God, and that
the Spirit of God dwells in you."
However, when you are without my felt presence is what you would have to say, I do not want
you to lose heart, but rather from today onwards.
When you are deprived of me, see this is why I only want to give you the deep privation
bit by bit, let us get it the way Louisa got it.
When you are deprived of me, I want you to take my divine will.
I want you to delight in my will.
I want you to love me and glorify me in my will.
And holding my will as if it was my very person, which it is, the divine will is the
essence of God.
By doing so, you will help me in your own hands.
You will have me in your own hands, and you can keep me there.
So this is a wonderful thing that he is telling her.
Now he says, "What is it that forms the beatitude of paradise?
What is it that makes heaven happy?"
He said, "Certainly it is my divinity."
Now what would form the beatitude of my dear ones on the earth?
With certainty, he said, "My will."
My will can never escape you.
Now as we go on in the volumes, he will explain that the divine will is in everything.
It is in every tree, every shrub, every animal, every stone, every planet, every molecule
of the air, water, etc.
It is in every molecule of us, otherwise we would not exist.
And if he took his will away from us, we would just simply cease to exist.
So he said, "You'll always have the divine will in your possession."
And if you remain within the circle of my divine will, now that circle we're going to
hear more and more about as we go on, because it's the infinite dimension of God.
And if you remain within the circle of my will, there you will experience joys most
ineffable and pleasures most pure.
Now that's expressed in Psalm 36 and it's 9 to 10 or 9 to 12, something like that, that
we drink from the torrents of his delight.
By never going out of the circle of my will, the soul becomes noble, she becomes divinized,
and all of her works and workings reverberate in the center of the divine sun.
That is sun with the capital S, you're not talking about the planet.
Just as the sun's rays, that's, now you're talking about the planet, reverberate on the
surface of the earth, not one of them goes out of their center, which is God, you see,
the divine will is there.
The soul who does my will, that means lives in the divine will, is alone the noble queen
who nourishes herself from my breath.
Now the breath of God is Ruach Adonai, that is the Holy Spirit, or UACH Ruach Adi-O-N-A-I,
Ruach Adonai, the breath of God.
So the soul who does my will is alone the noble queen who nourishes herself from my
breath, because she takes her food and drinks from no place but my will.
And by nourishing herself from my will, which is all holy, a most pure blood will flow in
her veins, and her breath will spread a fragrant perfume, which will cheer the whole of me,
because it is produced in my own breath.
It is not incredible, therefore I want nothing else from you, but that you form your beatitude
in the circle of my divine will, without ever going out of it, not even for a brief instant.
Now while Jesus was saying this, Louisa said, "I felt alarm and fear in my interior, that
this message of Jesus might indicate that he was not going to come, and that I was going
to have to find peace in his will only."
I think that's hilariously funny.
She would have the whole of him, he's just explained it.
But as far as Louisa is concerned, if I can see you and feel you and all the rest of it,
then I don't have you.
It's really fantastic.
I want to give you Sam 27 verse 9.
It shows you the level that which this woman is in love.
All she said, "What grips in my heart?
But Jesus, who is always good at it, how can I leave you since you are a victim soul?
This is the privilege of victim souls to have the Lord with them.
When you cease to be a victim soul, then I will not come.
But as long as you are a victim soul, I will always come.
I will always come."
I want to give you John 14, 18 there.
So it seems Louisa said, "I have remained at peace.
But I feel as though surrounded by the adorable will of God in such a way that I find no opening
through which to go out."
I want to give you John 14, 27 there.
Now you see, the circle of the divine will is infinite.
So if she perceives herself in it, naturally, there's no way out.
It's a bit like a tiny fish in the middle of the Atlantic Ocean being asked, "Are there
any lands around the place?"
The little fish doesn't know what a land is.
It only knows what water is and this watery environment that is its life.
And so Louisa said, "I find no opening through which to go out.
I hope you will always keep me in this circle that connects me completely to God."
Now, we're only on Volume 3.
Louisa is already lifted up to live in the divine will.
That means to operate completely on a divine level.
Now, Jesus is not going to confirm this to her until we're up in Volume 11 or 12.
And the reason is that he wants her to become more and more stable in this before he will
alert her to it, but he has given her the teaching, which is really fascinating.
And it's just that what he's saying to her is so new that the priests don't grasp it.
And therefore they don't ask her lots of questions.
And because they don't ask her lots of questions, she doesn't ask lots of questions either.
So February the 27th, 1900, the divine will binds Jesus to the soul.
Having abandoned all of myself in the loveable will of our Lord, now later on when we get
more teaching on the divine will, we're going to understand that this abandonment means
you fuse yourself in the divine will.
I saw myself surrounded completely by my sweet Jesus inside and out, because the same will
is now operating in Louisa as is operating in Jesus.
So he is in the center of Louisa and Louisa is in the center of him.
By having abandoned myself in him, I saw myself as if my being had become transparent.
Now transparent means spiritualized.
And that is the process of living deeper and deeper and deeper in the divine will, that
our souls become spiritualized, then gradually our minds and finally even the body.
So I want to give you John 3.21 there and Galatians 2.20.
I no longer live Christ lives in me.
Now wherever I turned, I could see my highest good.
This has been her problem.
I can't see him.
Now she realizes that inside in the divine will, of course she sees him.
But that which amazed me was that while I saw myself surrounded by Jesus inside and out,
so was I, my poor being, my will surrounding Jesus as though within a circle.
So there you have Louisa in the circle, which is Jesus and Jesus in the circle, which is
Louisa.
It's amazing.
I want to give you John 6.56 and John 14.21, you in me and I in you.
So so was I, my poor being, my will surrounding Jesus as though within a circle in such a way
that he would not be able to find an opening to go out, that he wouldn't be able to find
it.
Okay.
Not only could she not find a way out, he couldn't either because this is union.
They've become one because my will, united to his, kept him chained without any possibility
that he might escape or admirable secret of the will of my Lord in describable is your
happiness, she said, because she now knows that she's having an earthly experience that
they blessed have in heaven all the time.
Now while I was in this state, blessed Jesus told me, my daughter in the soul who is completely
transformed in my will, I find sweet rest.
So if you have your book open and you are reading it with me, I want you to put a big
line or a color on completely transformed because some people allow themselves to be
a little transformed.
They don't allow the 100% bit.
Her soul becomes for me, Jesus said, like those soft objects which cause no bother to
someone who wants to rest on the contrary be they even tired and suffering people, the
softness and the pleasure they give in resting over those objects as such, that when they
wake up they find themselves strong and healthy.
Such is for me the soul who is conformed to my will, I want to give you Romans 828 there.
And I, as recompense, allow myself to be bound by her will and I make the divine sun shine
in her as in full midday, there's nothing blocking the light from coming through.
Hence she noticed herself transparent, now in higher volumes she will actually acknowledge
what Jesus tells her that her soul has become like crystal and crystal allows light completely
through.
So having said this, Jesus disappeared.
Now we have a different subject, God hates us complaining.
We don't like people complaining either, but to complain behind people's back and turn
it into gossip is even worse and it's condemned by the Bible.
Then later after I received communion Jesus came back and transported me outside of myself.
I could see many people and Jesus told me, tell them that it is a great evil that they
do by murmuring against one another and about one another.
So he's including gossip there as well.
And if you have the book of Proverbs there's plenty in it about gossip.
He says they draw my indignation and with justice because I see that while they are subject
to the same miseries and weaknesses they do nothing but raise tribunals against one another.
So that's Christians taking Christians to court and Jesus says none of them are any better
than anybody else, they all have the same problems.
So I want to give you one Corinthian 6 verses 1 to 11 where Saint Paul tells the Corinthians
that it is a contradiction in terms that Christians would take one another to court.
And then Jesus said, "If they do this among themselves what should I who am pure and holy
do with them?
According to the charity with which they exercise towards one another, do I feel drawn to use
mercy with them?"
Now first of all I want to give you Matthew 7 1 to 5, do not criticize, do not condemn,
if you don't want to be condemned by our Justin Holy God.
So now he's saying that the amount of compassion and understanding and mercy that he feels
drawn to give us is the amount that we give to others.
And he did give us the golden rule that to do unto others, what we would like others to do unto us.
And he did order us in John 13 verses 34 to 35 that we're to love one another in the same
way as he loved us, which is sacrificially and with forgiveness and big heartedness.
Okay.
And in John 15, 9, Jesus says, "As the Father loves me, that's the way I love you.
That means unconditionally, absolutely, eternally with forgiveness, knowing your weaknesses."
And that's the way you're to love one another as well.
So Jesus was saying this to me, Louisa said, and I repeated it to those people and then
we withdrew.
So March the 2nd, 1900, we talk about union with Jesus.
This morning, after I received Holy Communion, my sweet Jesus made himself seen crucified.
And I felt drawn interiorly to reflect myself in him, to be able to become like him.
That's 2 Corinthians 3, 18.
And Jesus reflected himself in me, to draw me into his likeness.
And doing this, I felt the pains of my crucified Lord being infused into me.
And with all goodness he told me, "I want suffering to be your nourishment."
Now he's talking to her as a victim's soul.
It's not exactly the same with the rest of us.
And I want suffering to be your nourishment, not only as suffering, but as the fruit of
the divine will.
The most sincere kiss which binds our friendship more tightly is the union of our wills, the
Song of Songs 1-1.
Let him kiss me with the kisses of his mouth.
Now Louisa often got kisses from Jesus, but St. Bernard of Clairvaux did about 12 sermons
on "Let him kiss me with the kisses of his mouth."
And he warned people like me to be very careful about asking the Lord for this, because we're
much further back now than people like Louisa.
And he said that we have to learn first of all to kiss his feet in repentance as Mary
of Magdalene did.
And then gradually as we grow, we reach his knees and we kiss his hands as good disciples.
And then as we grow even more, we can kiss his heart as John did at the Last Supper.
And he may or may not ever give us the kisses of his mouth, because if you get it, you will
get the gall that was in his mouth.
You will get the terrible bitter breath that was inside of him.
You will get all his crucifixion, and usually the victim's souls are the ones who say yes,
much more quickly than the rest of us.
Some of the rest of us never get there.
So just to clarify when we use a language like this.
So Jesus says, "The most sincere kiss which binds our friendship more tightly is the union
of our wills, and the indissolable bond that will clasp us in continuous embraces will
be the continuous suffering."
So there's the victim's soul identifying completely with the crucified.
So while Jesus was saying this, "He on nailed himself, took his cross and laid it in the
interior of my body," Louisa said.
And I too was so stretched as to feel my bones being dislocated, which she describes in the
hours of the Passion happened to Jesus as they were nailing him.
Moreover, a hand, but I cannot tell with certainty whose it was, pierced my hands and feet through.
Jesus who was seated on the cross which lay in my interior was all pleased with my suffering,
and with the one who was piercing my hands, and he added, "Now I can rest in tranquility.
I do not even have to take the trouble of crucifying you, because obedience wants to
do it herself, that means that hand is the intention of the priest.
And I leave you freely in the hands of obedience.
And moving quickly upon the cross, he placed himself upon my heart to rest.
Now when Jesus finds rest in us, it means that we have taken upon ourselves to make
reparation and substitution for others, so that souls will be saved.
The only relief we can give Jesus is to give him souls."
Who can say how much suffering I remained in, Louisa said, being in that position?
After I remained like this for a long time, Jesus would not bother relieving me as at
other times, so as to let me return to my natural state, why?
Because he has abandoned her into the arms of the priest, and the priest won't even know
what's going on.
I could no longer see that hand which put me on the cross, and I said this to Jesus and
he replied, "Well who put you on the cross?
Did I perhaps do it?
It was obedience, that's the priest, and obedience must remove it, so Louisa is going to have
to talk a bit more to the priests now."
It seems that this time Louisa said he wanted to play, and by his highest grace I obtained
that Jesus would set me free, so Louisa pushed the button strong enough for Jesus to actually
do it one more time to set her free.
But what Louisa doesn't realize right now is that what is happening to her is a preparation
for the future in which the priest will have a much stronger role than he has now, and
therefore that Jesus won't be doing work that really somebody else should be doing.
So Mark VII 1900, this is union with the divine will.
This morning, finding myself outside of myself, I had to go round and round to find my blessed
Jesus.
Round and round for Louisa means through heaven and earth in and out of the body experience.
Fortunately I entered into a church and I found him on the altar where the divine sacrifice
was being celebrated.
Immediately I ran to him and I embraced him telling him, "Finally I have found you.
You made me go round so much to the point of tiring myself, and you were here."
And Jesus looking at me with seriousness, not with the usual kindness, told me, "This
morning I feel very embittered, and I feel the full need to lay hand on chastisements
to free myself of this load."
And Louisa said immediately, "My dear, I love the way she calls Jesus, my dear.
My dear, it's nothing. We will remedy it quickly."
Now the "we" is Philippians 4, 13.
I can do all things in Christ who gives me the strength.
I also want to give you Psalm 106 verse 23 that Louisa is willing to stand in the breach
to save the people.
And Isaiah 58 12, that it's a terrible thing if there's nobody who can stand in the breach.
So Louisa steps up to the plate, she said, "We'll remedy this. You will pour your bitterness
into me, and so you will be relieved of the load, isn't that right?"
And he, complying with my words, poured his bitterness into me.
And afterwards, clasping all of me to himself as if he had freed himself of a heavy way,
he said, "The soul who is conformed to my will knows how to infiltrate herself so much
into my power as to reach the point of binding me completely."
In other words, this level of communion with God in the divine will, and this level of
identification with Jesus in his sufferings, gives the soul a power that is divine.
It's really incredible.
She can reach the point of binding me completely, Jesus said, "And to her liking, she disarms
me as she wants."
Ah, you, you, he said, "How many times you bind me?"
And while saying this, he assumed his usual sweet and benign appearance.
So you're talking here about prayer combined with sacrifice.
So March the 9th, 1900, we're back to talking about grace.
As I was a little disturbed, now we know from Volume 1 you're not allowed to be disturbed.
Jesus doesn't want any disturbance in your interior, because your interior is the holy
of holies where he wants to dwell.
And if there is disturbance in it, it opens it up to attack from the evil one.
So he told us right from the very beginning in Volume 1 to make absolutely certain that
nothing gets into your innermost being.
So she said, "I was a little disturbed because of something which is not necessary to say
here.
My mind wanted to go wandering about so as to be assured about my disturbance and so
remain in peace.
The blessed Jesus wanting to contradict my will prevented me from seeing what I wanted.
And since I insisted in wanting to see, he told me, "Why do you want to go wandering
about?
Don't you know that one who goes out of my will goes out of the light and confines herself
in darkness?
And almost wanting to distract me from what I wanted, he transported me outside of myself.
Okay, let's stop there for a moment.
Jesus deliberately contradicted Louise's will.
You've heard me saying before that the moment we enter into this path, we have to take it
as our daily motto, "Not my will, but thine be done, O Lord."
And he will allow people to contradict you.
He will allow events to upset you in so far as it's cutting across your plans.
And we have to learn to ride with this.
And each time, take it as an opportunity saying, "Lord, what you're looking for is the gift
of my will and I give it to you, you're in control of everything."
Now, if we do this from the beginning, we will make huge strides.
If we don't, we won't get anywhere.
So I'll pick up with Louise again, and almost wanting to distract me from what I wanted,
she said, "He transported me outside of myself and changing the subject," he said.
Take a look at how ungrateful human beings are to me.
Now, throughout the 36 volumes, the human race is identified as completely ungrateful.
With the crisis that's in the country and the church at the moment, you'd have to agree.
People don't say, "Yes, please, thank you, sorry anymore," they've just dropped it.
Because if you drop religion, you also drop civilization.
It is religion that brought civilization to Europe.
And we're becoming more and more uncivilized.
So he said, "Take a look at how ungrateful human beings are to me."
The light of the sun fills the whole earth from one end to the other.
In such a way that there's no land which does not enjoy the benefit of its light, there's
no one who can complain about being without its beneficial influence.
In fact, investing the whole universe, the sun, takes it as though in hand to be able
to give light to everything.
Only one who escaping from the sand goes to hide in dark places can complain of not
enjoying its light.
And yet continuing its charitable office, the sun does not cease to send him a few glimmers
of light through its fingers.
I love that.
You pull down the shutters and the light gets around them.
Pull the curtains across and the light manages to find little place to come through.
And in the same way, for people who are resisting God and living in sin, he will get through,
he'll get to you and give you the opportunity to come back to him.
So he said, "This is what my grace is like.
The sun is an image of this, which my grace inundates people everywhere, the poor and the
rich, the ignorant and the learned, Christians and unbelievers."
That's terribly important.
John 10, 10, "Other sheep I have that do not belong to this fold and them also I must
bring."
No one, no one can say that he or she is without grace because the light of truth and the influence
of my grace fill the earth.
More than the sun fills the earth with light at midday.
So I want to give you Acts 17, 28, "But what pain I have in seeing people who passing
through this light with their eyes closed and confronting my grace with the pestilent
torrent of their iniquities, that is strong language."
They deviate from the light and they live voluntarily in dark places in the midst of
the most cruel spiritual enemies.
So I want to give you John 3, 19 to 21, where Jesus says that some people reject the light
and choose the darkness.
It's an awful mystery because the terrifying gift that God has given to us is free will
and we can say no and we can stay that way if we decide.
So we also use the expression there are none so blind as those who refuse to see.
So these people are exposed to a thousand dangers because not having light, which of
course is the presence of God in us, they cannot know clearly whether they are in the
midst of friends or enemies and therefore shun the dangers that surround them.
If the sun had reason and human beings were able to give this affront to its light and
some of them in order to irritate the light and not to see it would show such ingratitude
as to pluck their eyes out to be more sure of living in darkness and instead of sending
light the sun would send laments and cries of sorrow such as to turn all nature upside
down.
It's so crazy, yet that which one would have horror in doing to natural light, they reach
such excess as to do to migrate, treating it in this way.
But my grace is always kind to them and in the midst of darkness itself and of the madness
of their blindness it always sends limers of light because my grace never leaves anyone
and we know from volume two that God is grace.
It is man who voluntarily goes out of grace and grace not having him within itself tries
to follow him with glimmers of light.
Well, Jesus tried to get through to us on this subject in the wonderful parable of the
prodigal son and the parable of the lost son.
And of course it's the human race that is the prodigal son always wallowing in the lowest
activities when they were called to be eagles flying high in God's sky.
While saying this, Jesus was extremely afflicted and I did as much as I could to console him
praying him to pour his bitterness into me, Louisa said, and he said, bear with me if
I am the cause of affliction to you because once in a while I feel the necessity with
my beloved soul to pour out my pain in words for the ingratitude of the human race so as
to move their hearts to repair for such an excess.
I hear you've got a very tender moment in which Jesus says, would you bear with me for
Ohio?
I actually need to put words onto this.
I actually need you to hear in words the sorrow of your God watching the children that God
has given life and grace and everything to watching them destroy themselves and perhaps
if you hear my words you might actually turn and make some reparation.
He said, I want to move your hearts to repair for such an excess and I want to move your
hearts to compassion for human beings themselves because after all hell is a terrible place
to go to.
So Louisa said, Lord, what I would like is that you would not spare me the sharing of
your pains and as I tried to say more, he disappeared and I returned to myself.
You see, he couldn't give her more pains at that particular point.
Human nature can only take so much.
So March the 10th, 1900 and the subject here is suffering.
This morning, having received Holy Communion, I saw my dear Jesus as a child with a lance
in his hand in the act of wanting to pierce my heart through.
We have a very famous statue in the Carmelite Church.
I think it's in Clarendon Street showing Teresa of Avila receiving the lance from an angel
and it's shown in such dramatic lines that when I read Louisa, I just say, they've exaggerated
because God can do something very simply.
He doesn't need the terrible drama that was illustrated in the statue.
And this is the second time or third time that we've read this even in Volume 3.
So he had a lance in his hand and the act of wanting to pierce my heart through.
And since I had said something to the Confessor wanting to reproach me, Jesus said, you want
to shun suffering and I want you to begin a new life of sufferings and of obedience.
Now, you probably don't guess what the new life is, Louisa didn't either, although she
had started it and that is that she was to suffer on a completely new level which was
a divine level in the divine will.
And her obedience was also to shift up under this new level, the divine level and therefore
both the obedience and the love with which she obeyed and the sufferings were all going
to have an infinitely greater effect on the human race.
So while saying this, he pierced my heart with the lance and then he added, but before
we do that, I want to give you Luke 2.35, a sword will pierce your own soul too.
And Jesus explained, just as the fire burns according to the wood that is placed in it,
just being more active in burning and consuming the objects that are thrown into it and the
greater the fire, the greater the heat and the light that comes from it, the same with
suffering and obedience, he's trying to begin to tell her it's going to be a much greater
reality at the divine level.
So I want to give you Luke 3.16 and Luke 12.49.
So he said, it's the same with suffering and obedience.
The greater they are, the more the soul becomes capable of destroying what is material.
And obedience gives her the shape at once like soft wact.
Now he's been talking about that for a while, hasn't he?
I want to give you Hebrews 12.29, our God is a consuming fire.
Now fire is one of the great images that's used in the Bible.
God is called fire, I've just given you Hebrews 12.29, but God isn't always a consuming fire.
Moses met God as fire in the burning bush, but it was not consuming the bush.
And the apostles experienced God as fire on Pentecost day, but the fire didn't consume
them, not in the sense that we understand fire consuming, because when the Holy Spirit,
the fire of God enters into us, he does four things.
One, he cleanses and then he goes much deeper, he purifies, then he goes, he sanctifies and
then he glorifies, they are the four stages.
But fire is also the image of hell.
So how can the same fire be the image of heaven and hell?
Well, Matthew 3, 10 to 11 actually explains it.
So if you just write down CF, that is, you know, compare Matthew 3, 10 to 11.
Because Matthew says that he who is coming after me will baptize you with the Holy Spirit
and fire, that's the fire of love to cleanse and purify and sanctify and glorify us.
And he says, those who reject this will be thrown on the fire that never goes out.
Now the fire that never goes out is an inert fire, it never cleanses, it never purifies,
it never sanctifies and it never glorifies.
And therefore, this is one of the images of hell that a substance is put into it.
This never ever cleansed, you know, scientists have always used fire to cleanse gold and
silver, for example, of any dross that's in them.
But gold and silver put on an inert fire, nothing would happen, they would remain tarnished.
And so hell fire, while it's terrible and it's burning and it's torturing, it doesn't
produce anything, it's utter frustration.
So March the 11th, 1900, Louisa encounters a soul in purgatory and responds in a way that
utterly amazes me.
So it continues the same way, she said, this morning I saw good Jesus more afflicted than
usual, threatening a great mortality of people, this is a hint at World War I.
And I saw that in certain towns, many were dying.
And then I passed by a purgatory, she said.
And as I recognized a late friend of mine, I questioned her about various things regarding
my state.
Now, this is what amazes me, I thought that when you met the souls in purgatory, you were
supposed to be praying for their release.
But especially she said, whether my state is the will of God, Louisa keeps this up and
she's going to keep it up for about 15 or 16 volumes.
And whether it is true that it is Jesus who comes or the devil.
And Louisa said, I said to her, since you are in the presence of truth itself and you
know things with clarity, with no possibility of deceiving yourself, you can tell me the
truth about my affairs.
And the soul in purgatory said to her, do not fear your state is the will of God and
Jesus loves you very much.
This is why he is pleased to manifest himself to you.
Then Louisa said, I started proposing some doubts to her, prayed her to be so kind as
to see before the light of truth, whether they were true or false.
And to do me the charity, I thought it was supposed to be the other way around that we
did charity to the souls in purgatory, would never mind.
And to do me the charity to come and let me know.
And then Louisa said, and if she did that as recompense, I would have amassed celebration
for her suffrage.
Well, I thought you would do that anyway without making her pay for it, you know.
And the soul responded, if the Lord wants it, because we are so immersed in God that we
cannot even flutter our eyelashes, if we do not have his concourse, his agreement.
We dwell in God, just like a person who dwelled in another body, who can think, speak, look,
work, walk in so far as is allowed to him by that body which surrounds him.
So it's a bit like a hand in his love in a way.
So what happens is that Louisa gets an extraordinary revelation from this soul.
I mean, it's amazing to me.
And we normally have the image of the souls only in fire.
We forget to see that the fire of love is God.
And here this soul is saying that we are completely immersed in God and there's not
a thing we can do without God absolutely agreeing to it.
So obviously God agreed to that soul talking to Louisa or it wouldn't have happened.
So we dwell in God, just like a person who dwelled in another body, who can speak and
look and work and walk in so far as is allowed to him by that body which surrounds him on
the outside.
Now, here's an image of the souls in purgatory, completely inside the circle of the divine
will and until they are purified their experience of being in touch with the holiness of God
is painful.
And when the purification is over, then the painful aspect of it disappears and they move
into the glorious and celebratory part of God's love.
It's just a new image of purgatory, isn't it?
So the soul said, in fact, for us, it's not like for you.
You can exercise your free will.
For us, every will has ceased.
Our will is only the will of God and from it we live in it we find our contentment and
the will of God forms all our good and our glory.
And as she was showing in unspeakable contentment talking about the will of God, we separated
Louisa said.
Now, I think this is a most wonderful, wonderful picture of the souls in purgatory that's very
different to most people's image of them.
I think it deserves to be read over and over again.
And I'll just give you a little illustration, it's probably a million miles away from the
reality that they're experiencing, but then I've never been to purgatory.
If you've ever been in the presence of a very holy person, now, I don't just mean the physical
presence as in you stand beside them for five minutes.
But if you have to deal with a very holy person, their holiness shows up your unholyness.
They're not doing anything about it, they're just being themselves.
Their love shows up your own love.
Their sacrificial way of doing things shows up your selfishness.
And so your experience of being in that presence is uncomfortable and challenging.
And that's the description that's given to us here of the souls in purgatory, that their
experience of brushing up against this divine love is uncomfortable and challenging and
painful, but gradually, gradually, gradually, they mold into it and they become like that
which they worship.
I'm going to stop there for a while.